hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu blogmis
Tag 23 es ist der vorletzte Tag Leute
wir können es jetzt schon mal sagen ich
habe es geschafft vlogmas
2023 ist vollbracht und heute gibt's ein
fantastisches Video um diese ganze erra
noch mal schön abzurappen und zwar ein
Pinterest couple Shooting wir gegen
Timos Eltern junge Menschen gegen alte
na ja oder wir mit OS Eltern zusammen
und ja fangen wir mal an ja das ist das
Foto was wir nachstellen off Aug zu
Aug so ein bisschen Manfred schaffst du
es noch dein Kopf ein bisschen weiter
nach hinten zu kippen na klar ja gut so
okay okay dann machen wir jetzt mal die
Fotos sch Kü Kü auf genau aber bisschen
mehr am Hals nicht so hat gepupst ich
nicht mach mal nicht sonst
richtig schön romantisch ich GLB
sie weiter ich glaub wir haben
oder jetzt wird einmal
geswitcht okay Moment Moment Moment ich
war noch nicht bereit so guck wie
aussieht
[Musik]
PAP ne was bisschenan vielleicht wo
ist was machst du die valessa ist
bereit oh
[Musik]
super das erste Bild ist im Kasten super
gemacht Team
Klasse
dafotograf
und ja das nächste Foto würde ich sagen
ist gestoppt ja gut das nächste Foto ist
auch eins meiner Lieblingsfotos weil ich
einfach die beiden sehen möchte wie die
das nachstellen wollen wir brauchen
jetzt dafür christmasy Tassen und dann
einfach ganz cozy gemütliche Stimmung
aber ich würde sagen wir machen alle
Fotos hier drin o wir machen uns das
nicht unnötig kompliziert Kugel von der
wir gestern gesprochen haben was dar
besonders sie regt Mama auf und was noch
sie kann fliegen sie kann
[Musik]
fliegen
nicht so gut
[Musik]
funktioniert falsch rum merkt man doch
nach oben
Z ja okay
noch so so hoch
ja ja
okay aber fangen
okay wie wirfst du
[Musik]
sie e noch
werfen aus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
war wir haben hier technische
Schwierigkeiten wir melen uns gleich
wieder Motiv Nummer 2 jetzt nach
draußen ich habe doch in die gopron
weihnachtsteppich mit Weihnachts aber
den sieht man gar
nicht so Motiv Nummer 2 Leute jetzt
nimmt mal die zwei weihnachtstassen mit
ich nicht die Typ Licht brauchen wir
nicht ne kannst auchim so Filter drauf
legen dass das dann aussieht wie das
also der Manfred ach so sollen wir nach
da gedreht oder nach da Timo eigentlich
m nach da machen die
Tür stell dahin man okay
[Musik]
wirüberieren kannst
noch oben nein okay doch mal drin ist n
mal was
drin ichbe von Klein CIS zur
hapitzeit re hier oben Festchen so gut
Leute
jetztan jetzt hör mal auf
hallo rein okay haben
wir
man kriegt also nicht so viel Körper
Geller
Körper
ver weniger m verarschen
gerade
leiert und si uns
angeschnitten
komplett ja wir haben
gut die ist irwie komisch
auf Foto 2 ist im Kasten und jetzt kommt
die Lichterkette die freue ich mich ganz
besonders wenn wir uns einwickeln müssen
weil alles andere hat bis jetzt ganz gut
geklappt jetzt müssen wir uns in eine
Lichterkette einwickeln eine habe ich
gefunden ja die passt do super die ist
doch super perfekt die hat auch ein
Bommel aber jetzt musst Du sagen nur
weil sie rot ist wir stellen gerade nach
was wir eben schon alles gesagt rot ist
hast du do jetzt sag nur weil sie rot
ist nur weil sie rot ist nur sie rot ist
ja passt perfekt super ich die von dir
die du hast und dann ja Timo will wieder
cool aussehen mit der coolen Mütze nein
aber R weißen Outfit pas wohl gar nicht
bist rich B m gib mir mal die Mütze guck
wie aussieht da se ich do bestimmt total
aus ich find mega cool ich fin dich
immer
cool s so si a wie der Nikolaus wie sehr
freust du dich auf eine Skala von ein
bis
10 ich ja
eins und du Papa
zweinhalb sch ein bisschen mehr immerhin
ein bisschen mehr ja jetzt geht's auf
die Terrasse ich lieb es ich lieb alles
Hand im heutigen Tag ey das ist der
beste wirklich das ist der beste vlogmas
Tag bis jetzt macht mir am allermeisten
Spaß gut mssen auch an genau die
lichterkenen müssen an und der Baum muss
ungefähr jetzt nach da gezogen werden
ich glaub unten muss auch greifen te
oder mit der
Fuß ja oh Gott oh Gott mit mitüze sich
aus wie ein Vollidiot stimmt gar nicht
si mit ganz normal aus ich
muss und Papa kriegt die be die be hier
das passt super ihr seid ihr seid die
Beach Boys wir sind die Red Girls h
pro cozy Dad ist unser cozy Dad
he so Mama sieht aus wie ein
wichtelzwerk so warte ich muss euch
jetzt einwickeln uns beide so ach so
kannst du das kurz das Foto holen
[Gelächter]
weig ach ihr steht zueinander ihr steht
zu
Nichten ihr steht zueinander nee ne ne
ne nee nee ihr steht einfach so
zueinander also gerade gerade und ihr
haltet unten Händchen okay unten halt
ihr die genau und richtig so nah dran
weil wir werden euch ja jetzt
zusammenwickel kin geworden klein
geworden großen sch cm wieder hat früher
nichts ausg war war ich
muss Liebe jetzt das Fest der
Liebe wir sind fertig mit dem
fotoshoooting die Bilder müssen jetzt
noch bearbeitet werden und dafür
benutzen wir keinen geringeren Laptop
als den Creator z17 HX studio a V von
MSI der Creator z17 Studio Laptop
absolutes Beast für kreativ Schaffende
Leute der Bildschirm kommt mit einer
Auflösung von
2560 x 1600 und true Pixel Display was
grading und Bildbearbeitung zu einem
absoluten träumchen Macht für uns am
wichtigsten ist der Mix aus Mobilität
und maximaler Leistung wir waren viel
unterwegs und haben vlogm komplett in 4K
gedreht und hatten mit der eingebauten
RTX 4070 GPU und der 13 Generation des
Intel i9 Prozessors einfach den
perfekten Workflow für unsere kreativen
Apps wie Schnitt und
Bildbearbeitungsprogramme sind die 64 GB
Arbeitsspeicher mehr als genug um einen
reibungslosen Workflow zu garantieren
wer so auf der Suche ist nach einem
absoluten powerhouse im schlanken Design
der ist beim Creator z17 definitiv an
der richtigen Adresse Timo das hätte ich
nicht besser sagen können wir bearbeiten
jetzt die Bilder ich finde das mega gut
wie findest du das ich finde es am
besten von dem was wir haben ja ich
glaube auch also der Papa hat auch
manchmal
echt wie sieht das Original noch mal aus
so sehr white sehr hell sehr hell okay
müssen auf jeden Fall erstmal Belichtung
ballern ja ist es so weil jetzt
verschwindet dein weiß da drin so kann
man über die Lichter hier noch mal
korrigieren das ist nicht so ja siehst
du das nur das weiß nicht so krass poppt
ja wieso machst du dann Lichter und
nicht das weißtion beides eigentlich
ganz gut aber Lichter greift dann
wirklich sieht man jetzt hier meine
meine Jacke an dann auf jeden Fall sind
die Hauttöne da ganz anders bei denen
Christmas ja jetzt würde ich nur das Rot
raus
du wirst dich g so leuchtend machen ja
das ist
es Beste was wir kriegen oder ich finde
es ist richtig gut ja okay dann würde
ich sagen machen wir die restlichen
Bilder auch noch ja dann sind wir fertig
Vanessa okay übernimmst die Moderation
ne ja also wir hatten ja jetzt ein
Fotoshooting erinnert ihr euch daran ja
ist ja noch nicht so lange her und wir
haben jetzt die Bilder bearbeitet und
zeigen euch das Ergebnis mhm und dann
schauen wir mal wer gespannt schauen wir
mal was wird ne schauen wir was wird was
wird okay das ist Bild 1 Referenzbild ne
seht jetzt auch noch mal hier
eingeblendet und jetzt kommt das
[Musik]
erste
ja sind sch dr od mal sehen dein Papa
wie wie wie wie träumerisch wie
genießerischer schaut ne und das noch so
viel also das ist nicht cringy das ist
Liebe so sieht Liebe aus Leute aber
fällt euch auf dass der Tannenbaum
aussieht als ob er drin stehen würde ja
stimmt hast recht ja ja optische
Illusion würde ich sagen ja cool cool
Kön Photoshop ja so jetzt kommen wir oh
jaind weiter weggemacht weggezen das
hast Du tatsächlich am besser
fotografiert würde ich sagen ne muss ich
sagen tatsächlich also ich finde es ist
gelungener aufgrund von dem dass es ein
bisschen weiter weg Abstand hat bisschen
mehr sieht ja noch mal den Vergleich
noch den Vergleich sag
ja aber original ja fredel dran das ist
zu nah dran finde ich auch das ist
super sag ja gut gut also was
entscheiden wir welches welches Bild hat
gewonnen
unserss okay das hei ein für uns ja oder
für fre für die fotograen stimm ne ne
wir machen nach Bild jetzt Dach nach
Bild nicht wer gewonnen hat sondern das
Bild hat gewonen dann Bild Nummer zwei
ja hier haben wir die Szene gemütlich
vor der Tür man wartet vielleicht auf
die lieben auf die Verwandten oder man
genießt einfach den Morgenkaffee
zusammen an der Tür ja macht ihr
manchmal oder
äußerst selten steht ihr manchmal so
zusammen vor der Tür wir stehen oft
zusammen vor der Tür und schließen
auf
oh schon besser
nicht schlecht ne ne hat was find ich
auch nicht
schlecht Begeisterung bei Mama sieht
anders aus welcher welcher Begriff fällt
Dir da jetzt spontan
ein
[Musik]
schläfrig ich dachte sagst jetzt cringe
schläfriger kringchiger Blick
ja finde ich auch gar nicht oder do voll
das schöne Bild oder fin ich ich fin
auch gut ja gestern hat Mama die ganze
Zeit cringe gesagt wenn Sie die Bilder
ges ich find jetzt nicht schlecht ich
muss sagen ja ist okay okay
ja es sieht halt einfach besser aus
gell ich würde aber sagen der Fotograf
hat hier schon wieder tolle Arbeit
geleistet ja wobei ich finde mir ist
hier persönlich zu viel von diesen leere
Tür muss ich sagen hier ist der Fokus
voll auf euch hier hast du voll viel von
der Tür und das ist so aber du hast auch
eine weihnachtliche Tür deswegen ich
würde auch sagen es passt ich stimme für
das B finde ich schöner muss ich sagen
ich finde das tatsächlich auch schöner
ja runder andere schön das wir du
schöner ja obwohl viel viel Unterschied
ist da auch nicht du du wirkt
harmonischer ich möchte auch ein Punkt
so nächstes Motiv Motiv Nummer
3 war ja die vorlageinal sehr gut die
Vorlage ist gut ja sehr romantisch tolle
bunte Wollmützen und jetzt
kommt also das si ein bisschen heftig
aus machen den Vergleich das finde ich
da fehlt noch ein bisschen wir hätten
noch mehr mehr Lichter ja machen müssen
ja o hat ich finde timo hat aber auch
sehr dunkel bearbeitet aber fällt euch
fällt euch auf dass ihr im Hintergrund
keine Häuser mehr seht dass es aussieht
als ihr seid in einem großen Garten ja
groß ist er nicht aber aber auf jeden
Fall sieht man die Häuser stim wir
müssen eigentlich mal kurz einmal das
Original einblenden wie das Foto aussah
was wir geschossen haben ja und da sieht
man schon krassen Unterschied sieh man
schon Unterschied jetzt kommt unser okay
ah guck mal noch noch besserer
Hintergrund off Bäume kleiner Wald
original ja auf die Bäume K auch draf
Original war ganz gut Hintergrund und
die die Lichterkette ist hier optimaler
verteilt ja das muss ich aber s mein
Job abgeliefert unwi Vanessa
vaness also ich muss sagen das gefällt
mir
besser ironischerweise auch sagen Timo
also Papa hat echt besser fotografiert
als Timo ja stimmt ich bin da auch
wieder zu dran
gewesen ja Timo da hast du einfach
wirklich vielleicht hast Du daher auch
deine Skills geerbt 100
pro gut okay nicht schlecht hat euch das
Spaß gemacht doch ja schon auf jeden
Fall war auf jeden Fall gestern
lustig werdet ihr die Bilder posten oder
werden die für immer im Archiv landen
posten kann ich auf jeden Fall warum
nicht bei mir
bleibench Archiv dafür poste ich sie
dann PAP so nie was und dann kommt das
so nach Ewigkeiten Merry
CHM na ja
gut kann man zeigen defini ja und toller
Laptop oder absolut absolut ich bin
begeistert super alles klar Leute dann
war's das mit dieser Folge Timo
tollzügen toll gemacht und wir sehen uns
morgen dann zum allerletzten blogm fre
und wir wünschen frohe Weihnachten
allerseits ja das wünschen wir
jetzt jetzt und morgen noch mal morgen
noch mal natürlich tschüss